au début du quinquennat un certain
nombre de décisions qui l'avons
d'ailleurs soutenu sur les ordonnances
travaille sur des actions en matière de
l'alternance mais je dois dire que c'est
quand même un bilan dans lequel la
déception mais les relations avec le
sénat ont été des relations
vivante
nous avons voté beaucoup de textes près
de 70% que nous avons votée
ça ne se passe pas si mal ça du monde
que nous sommes toujours une assemblée
de la construction ici et pas une
assemblée qui se situe systématiquement
dans l'opposition par principe je disais
au moment j'ai été réélu ici sénat ont
dit jamais oui par discipline et jamais
non par dogmatisme ça s'est vérifié
au cours de ce quinquennat
[Musique]